for decades he was touted as the best of
the bonds but there's more to sean
connery's life than his days as a secret
agent
on october 31st 2020 the actor died in
his sleep in the bahamas following a
long illness
this is the story of his life beyond
bond born to a working-class family in
edinburgh scotland in 1930
thomas sean connery had a childhood that
belieled the glamorous life for which he
was eventually destined
including leaving school at the age of
nine to begin working to help his family
get by
i used to walk to work in the dark my
mother went to work at the same time
and then i used to go straight from
there at six
in the morning and go straight to school
like many young people connery did not
immediately gravitate to what would
become his very successful career
instead he joined the royal navy at the
age of 16 about a year after world war
ii ended
he spent not quite three years in the
navy earning the title of abel seaman
assigned to the hms formidable however
he was discharged at the age of 19
because of duodenal ulcers an affliction
which ran in his family
both before and after his stint in the
navy connery took on many odd jobs
such as delivering milk bricklaying
lifeguarding and even coffin polishing
in his spare time connery took up
bodybuilding competing in the 1953 mr
universe competition
though he eventually drifted away from
bodybuilding he used his physique as an
artist model at the edinboro college of
art
connery was repeatedly praised as one of
the sexiest men alive so it stands to
reason that he spent a good deal of his
youth engaged in activities that
centered on his body
and his beauty well i mean what are you
supposed to reply to that
sean connery was nothing if not a very
dedicated hard worker it seems he never
rested on his laurels even if it did
take him some jumping around from job to
job before he committed to acting
he spent about eight years modeling and
taking on bit parts and chorus parts in
stage plays tv and film before he got a
foothold in starring roles
his first major parts on the silver
screen was opposite lana turner in the
1958 film another time another place
four years later he would assume the
role that went on to make him world
famous
starring in the original james bond
movie dr no it is startling in
retrospect that a man from such humble
beginnings became nearly synonymous with
the sexy sophisticated international man
of mystery
it lends credence to the idea that
anyone really can become anything if
they put in the effort
and if they're very very lucky once
connery became bond it was all
uphill for his career many actors are
the progeny of other actors and connery
passed his acting genes down to his son
from his first marriage
jason connery though not as famous as
his father was jason has enjoyed a
steady stable career since appearing at
the age of 20 in the lords of discipline
in 1983.
aside from acting he has also held film
projects as director
starting with the film pandemic in 2008
in a funny link to his dad jason played
a film version of bond author ian
fleming in the tv drama spy maker the
secret life of ian fleming
though connery was known around the
world as sir sean connery for the last
20 years of his life it was a bumpy road
to his eventual nighting in 2000
it was widely rumored that he was twice
denied knighthood by donald duer
former scottish labour party politician
because of his political views
connery is a member of the scottish
national party a central left party
which favors scottish independence from
the united kingdom
needless to say scottish independence is
a bit of a snub to the good old queen of
england so it's fair to see that britain
may not want to extend the honor of
knighthood to a man so vocally opposed
to its monarchy
incidentally dwara passed away on
october 2000 just a few months after
connery received his knighthood
despite connery's dedication to the
scottish national party he seemed to
have been very proud of his knighthood
he was credited as sir sean connery in
more recent roles
though connery's rise from rags to
riches makes for an incredible story
there are a few shadier aspects of his
life and career
one of those being his allegedly fraught
relationship with taxes
connery was accused of being a tax exile
leaving away from scotland to avoid
paying income taxes
he released his tax information in 2003
to dispel these rumors though there are
claims that he would have paid more if
he had lived in the country at the time
he again came under fire for alleged
property tax fraud regarding a villa he
and his wife owned in marbella spain
though connery was acquitted his wife
micheline rockbroon was investigated
initially the fraud has been referred to
as operation goldfinger a callback to
one of connery's bond films
i think you've made your point
goldfinger thank you for the
demonstration
though we reached the end of his life
while living in the bahamas connery is
most inextricably linked with scotland
a place he maintained he would only move
back to if and when it gained
independence from britain
but there is another land that has
chosen to honor the famous scot
estonia more specifically the scottish
club of tallinn estonia funded a bronze
bust to the actor through private
donations
the scottish club begun as a society to
sample whiskey is comprised of estonians
enamored with scottish culture as well
as a handful of scottish expatriates
connery is not the first influential
scot the club is honored with a statue
his bus joins out of robert burns
the 18th century poet perhaps best known
for penning an odd laying sign and often
recognized as scotland's national poet
talon might seem like a strange location
for a society honoring scottish legends
but it's clear that the members who
raised about fourteen thousand dollars
to have the statute made are dedicated
to their cause
just about every celebrity has a pet
cause or area of activism that they
regularly support
for connery his own upbringing has
prompted an interest in education
he helped co-found the scottish
international education trust in 1971
with his friend sir jackie stewart to
financially support promising scots
achieve a better education
in fact connery donated his entire
salary from his work on the bond film
diamonds are forever to the trust
a song which his website claims was well
over one million dollars
his philanthropy doesn't stop there but
his site declines to list the apparently
myriad charities and worthy causes the
stars supported
instead it prompts visitors to consider
helping others as he has and lists his
main areas of interest
education culture and scotland it seems
he doesn't take his own big break for
granted
acknowledging that the help he received
as a young man made an immeasurable
difference
sean connery is a sex symbol the kind of
man many wouldn't be surprised to learn
has a long list of ex-wives and jilted
lovers
in fact he only has one ex-wife dion
salento and has been married to his
second wife micheline rockbroon since
1975.
brock brune is an accomplished painter
who favors portraiture and bright hues
her gallery available to view on her
husband's website her long marriage to
connery though it seemed amicable enough
even despite her taking the fall and
their tax fraud scandal hasn't always
been the perfect pairing however
the man best known for portraying the
chauvinistic bond has had some misogyny
problems of his own
including a very public romantic affair
with pop star lindsay depaul a woman 18
years as junior
still rock broon remained with connery
until the end of his life
perhaps the most distinctive thing about
connery for many film-goers is his voice
that deep rolling scottish brogue
despite this he hasn't done a wealth of
voice work limiting such roles to a few
special projects
one of those projects was the 2005 video
game from russia with love for which he
reprised his role as james bond
long before that he played draco the
computer-generated dragon and
dragonheart
the last dragon on earth draco teams up
with an erstwhile dragon hunter a monk
and a young woman on a quest to save
england from a tyrannical king
it's a fun sentimental fantasy adventure
and connery's draco
holds up surprisingly well the less said
about the franchise that followed the
better
as recently as 2012 connery came out of
retirement to play the title role in the
film sir billy an animated film about a
scottish veterinarian that connery
produced
his tone and delivery also make him a
natural choice for a narrator a role he
spilled only once for a tv documentary
other than that the best way to hear the
man is to watch him in the flesh and one
of the many many films he left behind is
his legacy